[Musique]
vous êtes à la fin d'un jeu télévisé
il y a trois rideaux ou devant vous
derrière l'un des rideaux se trouvent
une voiture derrière les deux autres il
y à une chèvre
le présentateur un certain monty vol
vous demande de choisir l'un des rideaux
vous décidez de prendre le rideau du
mieux parce que parce que bon il n'y a
pas de raison de choisir un rideau
plutôt qu'un autre
mais mon petit rôle est un animateur
télé autrement dit c'est presque un
youtuber et du coup ils adorent faire
monter le suspense
justement pour faire monter le suspense
monte roll va révéler une chèvre et
comme il sait que derrière les rideaux
que vous n'avez pas choisi il ya
forcément une chèvre il y à un de ses
rideaux qui peut révéler et en effet il
révèle alors le rideau de droite qui
cache une chèvre mais mon rôle est aussi
un petit malin qui adorent mettre ses
invités dans des situations de dilemme
et il vous propose donc un dilemme
il vous propose de rester sur votre
choix du rideau du milieu ou de changer
de rideau en passant à celui de gauche
que faire la première intuition est elle
toujours la bonne ou n'y at il que les
imbéciles qui ne changent jamais d'avis
ou encore est ce que joseph est ce que
ça change vraiment quelque chose de
changé de rideau je vous invite à mettre
pause et à y réfléchir
allez encore 5 secondes pour mettre
pause 3 2 1
le problème que je viens de présenter
est devenu un grand classique des lois
des probabilités
vous en avez d'ailleurs déjà peut-être
entendu parler en fait il y a même
énormément de vidéos à ce sujet et tout
en arrive à la même conclusion
mais pendant longtemps étrangement ou
semblait encore loin d'un consensus à ce
sujet
ce problème a en effet été introduit en
1959 par le génial mathématicien
récréatif martin garner danse à une
critique américaine avant d'être
redécouvert et publiée dans le journal
american statisticienne en 1976 mais
c'est vraiment en 1990 que le destin du
problème dumontier roll a pris un
tournant grâce à la mathématicienne
marivaux savantes et son impressionnant
cuit de 228 celle ci tenait une
chronique appelé à ce que marilyn dans
la revue pride et en particulier suite à
une lettre d'un lecteur le 9 septembre
1990 marine vos savante publia une
démonstration mathématique de la
solution du problème et ce fut le début
du shit storm
suite à cette publication marc et il
vaut savante reçues autour de dix mille
lettres y compris mille lettres de
détenteurs de doctorat c'est à dire
quelque chose comme bac + 8
imaginez ça moi recevoir 100 tweets
mécontents c'est déjà une chips tort
mais la marilyn vos savante reçu cent
fois ça biya
beaucoup de ces critiques venait de gens
très compétents y compris des
enseignants et des chercheurs en
sciences et en mathématiques qui plein
de condescendance de sarcasme et de
virulence se permirent de comparer
marilyn vaut sa vente à une chèvre
roberts axe professeur de mathématiques
à george mason university écrivit vous
vous êtes planté en tant que
mathématicien
je suis très préoccupé par le manque de
compétences mathématiques du grand
public
s'il vous plaît aidez en confessant
votre erreur et en étant dans le futur
plus prudente
mary jane style professeur de
mathématiques à palm beach junior
college ajoute à notre département de
maths a eu un beau fourrière tout à fait
méritée à votre dépend ribot beau
professeur de mathématiques à georgetown
university écrivit vous vous trompez
complètement
combien de mathématiciens irrité vous
faudra-t-il pour changer d'avis même le
très grand mathématicien polaire deux
pris publiquement position contre vos
savante
personnellement j'ai régulièrement peur
que ce qui est arrivé à marie n'gbo
savante m'arrive à moi aussi
on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une erreur et
subir ce genre de réaction massive
surtout venant de gens avec une certaine
respectabilité
c'est extrêmement blessant ce qui est
clair c'est que si ça m'était arrivé
j'aurais très mal dormi pendant
plusieurs jours ça me semble même
probable que jean
et primes subir ce bowling massif c'est
psychologiquement très difficile sauf
que dans le cas de marie line meaux
savante ces critiques étaient à côté de
la plaque
la démonstration qu'elle avait publiées
étaient justes et les critiques se
tromper complètement dans leur
raisonnement ces critiques étaient
condescendant sarcastique virulent
diplômés respectable et respecté ces
critiques étaient sûrs d'eux ils
parlaient avec éloquence et sans
hésitation ils n'avaient pas l'ombre
d'un doute mais ils avaient tort
et oui moi aussi au moment de parler du
sol qui accélère vers le haut de série
divergentes ou de super intelligence
j'ai subi ce genre de critiques
condescendante sarcastique et virulente
pire sans doute parce qu'ils étaient en
excès de confiance et l'ignoré
complètement l'étendue de leur ignorance
même une démonstration mathématique
rigoureuse et pédagogique était
incapable de faire réfléchir les
critiques aussi brillant et diplômés
était-il leur intuition avait tranché et
leur réseau était devenu dévoués à leur
intuition erronée comme le dirait
johnathon rights in china post with any
sekkat
et au final même si je compatis
énormément avec marie n'gbo savante qui
a dû subir un énorme levée de boucliers
est une méga shipstern pour avoir publié
une démonstration juste c'est surtout la
réaction de ces critiques qui me fait
réfléchir
j'aurais tellement honte d'être à leur
place et j'ai tellement peur d'avoir
déjà souvent été à leur place c'est à
dire avoir critiqué les mauvaises
personnes pour les mauvaises raisons
en mode shipstern parce qu'à ce moment
j'étais en excès de confiance et pensait
que la bonne chose à faire
la chose morale à faire c'était de
participer au mouvement massif de
critiques de ces personnes
par exemple quand j'ai critiqué la
marche des sciences est ce que j'ai
appelé l'hooliganisme scientifique je me
dis que j'ai peut-être été trop sûr de
moi et que j'ai peut-être parler trop à
l'affirmative et que du coup j'ai
peut-être blessé les organisateurs et
gelé peut être même fait pour des
mauvaises raisons si c'est le cas je
vous présente toutes mes excuses
idem quand je critique la démocratie et
la paix value ou le réalisme moral
j'espère ne pas être un excès de
confiance j'espère ne blesser personne
et j'espère surtout ne pas faire du mal
en voulant faire du bien oui parce que
la leçon principale attirer des
mésaventures des critiques de marilyn
vos salles 1 tu sais que même lorsque
l'on est un génie surtout dès qu'il
s'agit de probabilité c'est extrêmement
dur de ne pas se tromper
surtout si on s'appuie sur un
raisonnement partiellement intuitif et
c'est encore plus dur de prendre le
temps d'envisager la possibilité que
notre intuition se trompent
or les raisonnements probabiliste sont
devenus omniprésents
quand on parle des impacts des ogm sur
la biodiversité de la régulation des
marchés financiers ou des effets du
véganisme sur notre santé ou ne peut
raisonner que de manière probabiliste
quand on parle de risque nucléaire de
culpabilité d'un individu ou de
conséquences sociales des ja
on ne peut raisonner que de manière
probabiliste quand on parle du futur du
travail des préférences morale ou 10 à 2
niveaux humain
on ne peut raisonner que de manière
probabiliste
et comme on y va généralement avec une
bonne grosse part d'intuition
il faut s'attendre à ce que l'on soit en
train de mal envisager ces problèmes et
à ce que certaines voire la plupart de
nos actions que l'on croit clairement
bénéfique pourrait en fait être très
néfaste quand votre intuition vous fait
prendre des positions tranchées
je vous invite
à prendre du recul et à penser à marilyn
vos savantes et à penser surtout aux
critiques de marilyn vaut sa vente
d'ailleurs pour ce problème du monty
rôle dites moi
de quel côté êtes-vous et surtout de
quel côté étiez vous avant d'apprendre
la solution à ce problème
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut garder
le rideau initiale ou qu'il faut changer
ou que ça n'a aucune importance
et surtout quel degré de confiance aviez
vous ou avez vous en votre réponse
intuitive et êtes vous sûrs d'avoir en
tête
un raisonnement valide pour en arriver à
votre conclusion
bon je vais arrêter de jouer les
présentateurs télé et on va mettre fin
au suspense dans ce problème il faut
changer de rideau en effet en changeant
de rideau vous doublez vos chances de
gagner la voiture
et oui je sais c'est ultra contre
intuitif mais c'est la conclusion à
laquelle aboutit le raisonnement
probabiliste or je fais beaucoup plus
confiance à ce raisonnement probabiliste
cas mon intuition et je fais même
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus confiance à ce
raisonnement probabiliste quand l'avis
des experts
autrement dit si demain j'ai aboutissait
à une conclusion suite
un raisonnement bayésiens exact et si
j'étais sûr à 99 999 % de la validité de
ce raisonnement bayésiens alors je ferai
largement plus confiance aux
raisonnements bayésiens cas l'avis des
experts et leurs intuitions y compris
s'il ya un consensus opposé des experts
à l'instar de marilyn vos soldes même si
des statisticiens affirme que je me
trompe
à moins qu'ils révèlent une erreur dans
le raisonnement bayésiens c'est au
raisonnement bézian que je ferais
davantage confiance c'est ça être
aspirants parisien sait faire avant tout
confiance voire entièrement confiance
aux lois des probabilités
alors bien sûr en pratique pour des
problèmes complexes comme le changement
climatique
le raisonnement probabiliste et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop complexe à faire
y compris avec des machines et du coup
c'est généralement le consensus
scientifique qui devient la meilleure
solution pragmatique pour se faire un
avis mais le problème de bons tirs hall
est suffisamment simple pour qu'on
puisse effectuer le raisonnement
parisien exact et c'est de ce
raisonnement bayésiens qu'on va parler
pour finir cette vidéo mais avant d'en
arriver là je précise que le
raisonnement vraiment bayésiens n'est
pas le seul qui permet d'orienter notre
intuition vers la bonne réponse je vous
recommande en particulier les
excellentes vidéo de la statistique
explique et à mouche à deux professeurs
culture précieuse de richard tailler et
de maths un peu ça pour découvrir des
preuves mathématiques des variantes
théoriques et des simulations empirique
qui permette d'aiguiller l'intuition
mais je précise aussi un point qui me
semble important aucune de ces vidéos ne
présente vraiment le raisonnement
parisien du coup après avoir vu ces
vidéos vous aurez peut-être l'impression
de mieux comprendre le problème de bons
tirs rôle mais ce n'est pas mon but dans
cette série car comprendre un problème
c'est cool mais comprendre la méthode
générale pour résoudre tous les
problèmes c'est quand même plus
important et c'est vraiment ça l'un des
objectifs principaux de cette
ris je vais vous présenter la méthode
qui selon la pure bêtise yen et la
méthode ultime pour résoudre tous les
problèmes du problème du monty rôle au
changement climatique en passant par la
physique théorique
la psychologie humaine et à prédiction
du futur de l'humanité
je veux vous faire découvrir le boys and
is
alors bien sûr on peut se demander si la
pure by then a raison de faire 100%
confiance à sa méthode
mais avant d'en venir là et je vous le
promets on y viendra je vous demande de
faire pour l'instant l'expérience de
pensée qui est là en fr raison à 100% de
faire confiance aux raisonnements
probabiliste pour découvrir les
conséquences je vous invite notamment à
calculer ce fameux terme d'expérience de
penser associés aux boys à nice mme
assez bavardé passons à la solution bei
viennent
celle ci correspond à appliquer la
formule deux pays et pour cela il faut
commencer par explicité notre préjugés
avant que monty rôle ne fasse quoi que
ce soit que pouvait-on penser
eh bien faute d'avoir accès à une étude
des endroits où monty rôle à l'habitude
de cacher la voiture il semble que l'on
ne puisse pas dire grand chose les trois
rideaux semble indiscernables donc il
semble raisonnable de dire que les trois
rideaux son équipe probable c'est à dire
que pour chaque rideau la voiture a une
chance sur trois que se trouvait
derrière ce rideau
on a donc initial trois théories avec la
même probabilité puis on a choisi le
rideau du milieu ce qui ne devrait pas
changer ses probabilités mais ensuite
montils rôle révèle la présence d'une
chèvre derrière le rideau de droite
c'est une information qui devrait nous
forcer à mettre à jour une crédence et
pour y arriver il nous faut estimer les
termes d'expérience de penser associés à
chacune de nos trois théories
souvenez-vous pour calculer le terme
d'expérience de penser d'une théorie il
nous faut nous placer dans un univers
alternatif où la théorie est vrai et
calculer la probabilité des données ici
le fait que monter rôle révèle la porte
de droite
dans cet univers alternatif le cas
simple est la théorie la voiture est à
droite
cette théorie est incompatible avec la
donne est observée ou plus exactement la
probabilité de voir une chèvre à droite
dans un monde où la voiture est à droite
est nul
le terme d'expérience de penser de cette
théorie est donc égale à zéro passons à
la théorie la voiture est à gauche
dans ce cas mon héros n'en fait pas le
choix s'il veut révéler rideau avec une
chèvre
alors il est obligé de révéler le rideau
de droite autrement dit la théorie
la voiture est à gauche prédit la donne
est observée de manière univoque son
terme d'expérience de pensée est donc
égale à 1
enfin il nous reste la théorie la
voiture est au milieu cette fois monter
rôle peut révéler le rideau de gauche ou
de droite
lequel va t-il révélé parce que ces deux
rideaux sont a priori indiscernables il
semble raisonnable de dire qu'il a
autant de chances de révéler le rideau
de gauche que celui de droite
du coup cette fois la prédiction de la
donne est observée n'est plus univoque
on prédit la donne est observée avec
probabilité 1/2
autrement dit et on insistera davantage
dessus dans les vidéos à venir dans
cette théorie on est un peu surpris que
ce soit le rideau de droite qui est
aidée ou
r selon cette théorie n'aurait après
tout puis observer une autre donnée quoi
qu'il en soit du coup un demi est le
terme d'expérience de penser associé
avec cette troisième théorie on a
maintenant ce qu'il faut pour calculer
les scores des différentes théories en
multipliant le préjugé de chaque théorie
par son terme d'expérience de penser on
obtient un tiers un sixième et zéro pour
faciliter les calculs vu que ce qui
compte ce sont les scores de chaque
théorie relativement aux scores des
autres
on peut multiplier tout ça par six ce
qui nous donne 2 1 et 0 en particulier
on voit que la théorie la voiture est à
gauche et désormais deux fois plus
probable que la théorie la voiture et au
milieu pour obtenir les probabilités des
deux théories on peut maintenant
appliquer la forme de baisses ou tout
simplement comparer le score de chaque
théorie au total des scores de toutes
les théories
on voit alors que la théorie la voiture
est à gauche a une probabilité deux
tiers contre nous probabilité un tiers
pour la voiture est au milieu qu'elle
était bel et bien les résultats de
marine volante
il faut changer vous doublez vos chances
en changeant de rideau mais encore une
fois j'ai envie de dire osef de la
solution du problème
ce que j'aimerais que vous reteniez
c'est que d'une part le raisonnement
bayésiens peut complètement divergé du
raisonnement intuitif mais aussi
j'espère vous avoir aidé à sentir les
étapes indispensables à ce raisonnement
bayésiens et comment les effectuer en
pratique de manière grossière il faut
commencer par identifier les théories à
considérer puis d'écrire notre préjugés
sur ces théories ensuite pour chaque
théorie il faut effectuer une expérience
de pensée qui détermine si les données
observées sont surprenantes dans le
cadre de telle ou telle théorie puis on
calcule le score de chaque théorie en
multipliant sacré danse a priori par sa
capacité à prédire les données observées
enfin on peut conclure en comparant le
score de chaque théorie au score des
autres théories bien sûr dans le cas
général ce raisonnement bayésiens prend
beaucoup de temps il faut nous contenter
d'approximations mais pour arriver à
être pas trop mauvais dans ces cas
complexes il est utile de s'entraîner
notamment avec des problèmes simples
comme monty rôle ou l'énigme des deux
enfants voilà en particulier qui devrait
nous forcer à
davantage de modestie épistémique est
sans doute à y réfléchir à deux fois
avant de critiquer qui que ce soit la
prochaine fois que vous voudrez incendié
quelqu'un je vous invite à respirer un
coup et a pensé à marilyn
la nymphe avait introduit la formule du
savoir et qui fera ne fait remarquer
qu'il a eu peur de ne pas s'accrocher
que c'est difficile s'est pris un vidéo
ne sont pas les plus faciles en fait de
cette série on introduit un petit peu le
formalisme et surtout une toute nouvelle
façon de penser et c'est extrêmement
perturbant de prime abord ce n'a pas à
voir avec la difficulté intrinsèque du
problème si je pense que c'est vraiment
que c'est très différent de ceux dont
son habitude mais du coup il faut juste
prendre l'habitude de raisonner ainsi
nous vous invitons en a à voir et à
revoir et à re voir pas mal ces vidéos
si tu veux vraiment vous familiariser de
plus en plus avec cette terminologie et
cette façon de penser est a priori si
vous faites ça de plus en plus vous
allez finir par trouver ça plus facile à
assimiler aller de l'avant je suis
désolé de faire des trucs un petit peu
compliqué au début malheureusement si je
pense que c'est utile d'en passer par là
mais même si vous n'avez pas compris ses
premières vidéos
il vous invite fortement essayer de vous
accrocher car
petit à petit les choses s'éclairciront
notamment une fois que vous avez vu
cette vidéo c'est peut être une bonne
idée de revenir à vide et aux précédents
toutes celles dont encore avant pour
voir les différents liens entre tout ça
et peut-être que cette vidéo typiquement
va clarifier la vidéo précédente
mathématiques fait la remarque que nos
préjugés sont parfois pires que le
hasard alors ceci dit contrairement à ce
qu'il affirme il me semble que non ils
ne sont pas toujours pire que le hasard
c'est à dire qu'il ya des cas où quand
même on peut se dire que on a un réfugié
meilleur que le hasard
par exemple si je tire une carte au
hasard dans un jeu à bien mélanger
a priori ce ne sera pas là ce de pique
je pense que c'est un préjugé qui est
assez assez valider mon cm mêmes
préjugés un peu plus précis que ça
puisqu'une préjugés c'est que il ya une
chance sur 52 que ce soit l'as de pique
même façon si je devais parier sur la
météo de demain à lausanne
eh bien je parierais assez
raisonnablement qui nous nagera pas ça
c'est un genre de prédictions aussi que
l'on peut faire et qui montrent que nous
prévienne ne sont pas toujours pire que
le hasard
ceci dit il arrive des cas où notre nos
préjugés sont pires que lazard et
notamment je vous recommande notamment
ce merveilleux ted de hans rosling qui
pose des questions où nos préjugés sont
globalement pire que le hasard et c'est
super utile d'identifier ces canaux prêt
géant du canot prix jules et intuitif
sont pires que le hasard puisque après
on peut faire appel un préjugé sur nos
préjugés intuitif qui serait fesses de
préjugés un peu plus réfléchi et si
jamais le préjugé réfléchit on vient à
cette conclusion il aura tout intérêt à
remplacer les préjugés intuitif par une
pompe est l'incertitude sur les
différentes hypothèses a priori en
particulier ceux que l'exemple de
mathématiques montre très très bien
c'est qu'il ya une différence entre des
préjugés intuitif que l'on a et préjugés
que l'on aurait si on réfléchissait
notamment davantage à tout ce que l'on
sait en particulier le calcul des
préjugés est un problème très difficile
en tant que tel c'est pour ça que je
vous pose dans ces paribas et bien c'est
pour vous amener à réfléchir à vos
préjugés parce qu'on a des préjugés
intuitif mais c'est pas forcément les
préjugés que l'on aura si on réfléchit
c'est davantage notamment comme ça si je
prends le mot préjugés au sens littéral
d'hier jugée avant et j'espère que
j'avais mais certains épisodes et que ça
nous permet de mieux comprendre ce que
j'entends par raisonnement bayésiens
c'est à dire vraiment collé finalement à
la formule de baisse
la prochaine fois on appliquera cela au
fameux problème des deux enfants où on
essaiera enfin de proposer une solution
vraiment bayésienne à cette énigme des
deux enfants si vous avez aimé cet
épisode de penser à le like à
l'augmenter à nous partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci aux ti
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois
imaginons que nous n'avons pas trois
portes mais 20 portes derrière l'une
d'elles une voiture est derrière les 19
autres une chèvre vous choisissez une
porte puis le présentateur décide
d'ouvrir toutes celles que vous n'avez
pas choisi
sauf une et toutes révèlent des chèvres
maintenant si on nous propose de changer
d'avis on aurait tendance à prendre sept
ports si effectivement ils étaient sur
la bonne porte
ça c'était la bonne il n'a pas intérêt à
changer ça ça arrive une fois sur trois
par contre dans deux fois ce dans deux
cas sur trois les fois où ils avaient la
mauvaise on sait où elle est si ça c'est
la mauvaise porte comme ça c'est la
mauvaise aussi la bonne elle est là
nécessairement donc dans deux cas sur
trois la bonne porte c'est celle là